[Music]
everyone is the daily Danni live and
what we normally reserved for new music
Friday is now Betty who Friday we're
dedicating this entire show to the queen
of pop pop Wow thank you so much Wow
well thanks for being here thank you
well hey whoo crew if you guys are
watching now it's your chance to ask
Betty anything you want just holler
right there in the comment comments
section and we're getting right here to
the iPad but uh there's so much to talk
to you about cuz you got a new EP come
in this summer dude just so exciting
because it's the first in five years
yeah it's I so I had my first two EPS
were like when I was just a baby
I know gosh you know it's been a while
since I've done something it's a little
it feels a little bit less pressure you
know an album is so like I I'm so kind
of like addicted to the process of
putting together a record and making it
perfect it's gonna put together an EP
it's a little like simpler for me I
don't think it's crazy about it really
yeah problems are so much longer and you
want them to feel like it's a story it
takes you on a journey right and so an
EP is more like you know it's it doesn't
have to feel is I think cohesive or it's
like no it's just as like a tick
you guys get it every single we're gonna
mention in many many okay but you're
right because you don't have to worry
about the flow of songs you just have to
worry about the songs that you care
about right and put them out totally so
Betty part one is the name of it June
15th is a release day yes um I mean I
know it's your first and five years but
you've been busy
oh yeah you know since that last record
um I mean what would you say has changed
the most about you in five years wow you
know probably my social essence I don't
really have one no no you know it's
funny my my mom and I had a conversation
very early on when I started sort of
doing this I was crazy busy and I was
never home for longer than five days at
a time you know it's like this is like
hashtag this is what dreams are made of
yeah and so I kind of I remember calling
her being like I miss my life and I miss
my friends and like and she kind of like
stopped me and was like this is your
life now
so you're don't you don't miss your life
you you're living your life I know it's
so wise I was gonna say that should do
it
perspective
she gave you some perspective gosh I
kind of it's that's I think the thing
that's changed the most is like my kind
of work ethic she's just like you have
to get your head around like being busy
all the time and I mean excites about it
before this interview we were talking
about the long weekend I get a long
weekend I'm going to Disneyland today
interview no I'm not in fact should we
tell them what you're doing this show we
can tell them she is filming a music
video for her new single taste yes I am
which is amazing I'm really really
excited I think it's gonna be really hot
okay what can you tease besides that
it's hot like what can we expect I don't
want to taste too much but I will tell
you that I was in the studio learning
choreography for it and all night last
night and there may or may not be a like
high-heeled dance that is really sexy
and I think really fun and I think it'll
be really fun for people to learn that's
really good please yes we got some
choreo too much right yes but a dance
break dance definitely Daniel I'll take
it oh it's gonna be so fun I mean the
single is so fun taste what a sexy out a
single art by the way Queen of Hearts
like kind of a weird like Siamese twins
I've you brought it and we are really
really good um I heard that it was
actually written about snack food yes is
that true it is true I can't believe
that I have like it and put myself in a
position where I get to talk about like
chocolate this is your life I was
talking about a chocolate kind of candy
it was it's a Norwegian oh it's a
specific truly specific I was I did a
writing camp in Norway and I was with a
friend of mine in our last session and
it was me and him and two of these like
lovely like such adorable Norwegian boys
okay who were like oh you've never had
this candy smash like you're gonna die
for it we're good and they were like I'm
sure there's some around like I'll find
some and I was like it's really okay
like it's like 10:00 in the morning like
I don't need candy right now yeah and he
was like no no you have to have it so
one of them literally left the studio
and went to 7-Eleven he came back like
half an hour later he like made a trek
he was like this is this important to me
and he went and got us this candy when
he brought us a bag of it and I was like
damn it it's so it's a gross kind of but
it's so good and I was like why is this
happening to buy
you tell me about this I'm gonna eat 17
bags of this before I fly out and then
we were kind of inspired Wow and started
writing taste and that's how it came to
be that's when you know a candy is that
good when you decide to write a song
about right you know some people are in
the studio writing about love heartbreak
Betty's talking about chocolate so much
so you know this this next EP is also
the first free of the label yeah it's
the first time you really put something
out on your own since you were like nine
yes I mean how has that affected your
process and and and your writing it's of
course like you know very it's a very
different time in my life now than I
thought I was when I was 19 and I put
out my first EP you know kind of I think
you have nothing to lose because you
have nothing to show for anything yet so
I think when I was really young it was
sort of just like I was testing right
you know I don't know what's gonna work
for me so let's see what happens and
that has always actually you know ended
up really well doing really well for me
I kind of I think I I was very lucky in
that way where I didn't have to try a
bunch of different stuff to finally
figure out I did that sort of privately
and the first thing I really put out I
was really proud of so I think now that
I've had sort of like five or six years
of kind of working in this industry
under my belt you know of experience I
think I'm much more informed about what
I want and how I want to sound and the
kinds of songs I want to put out and
also like you know playing with the you
know taste especially these are really
different vibe for me you know it's it's
kind of like rock and roll I think I I
think I recently described it as like
vampire fetish know kind of like it sort
of sounds like that a little bit and so
that's really different and that's a to
you but I think you know maybe two years
ago I would have been like this is too
different and I don't know how this is
gonna like fit in an album you know I
don't know where it's gonna fall and now
I'm kind of like no I love this song I
want to put it out and I know enough
about myself to go like I am willing to
take a risk on stuff that I think is
that I love and hope that you know my
fans will like it too because you can
like you're free of any expectations
from the powers that be for those glass
buildings and you know it's you have to
like you know you're freezing and I
think it's just about you know any
artist doesn't like to be told what to
do I'm incredibly stubborn to ask my
fiance so I think like even in my
personal life for God less it's just
like it's really liberating and
invigorating for me to be in this place
in my life where I feel like I'm I'm far
more growing up you know then just
emotionally I know if is it like you
know literally but emotionally I feel
far more grown-up than I ever have and I
think that I'm kind of in this place now
where I really want to take advantage of
that and go like no I want to be in
charge of my own destiny I want to like
make these decisions on my own like I
don't I don't want to have to not put a
song out because somebody else doesn't
like it it's an I like it I want to do
it like yeah this is my voice this is my
story I want to tell it the way I want
to I mean your music is a reflection of
you and it should be totally sometimes
you know we you're constrained yeah you
know there's pressure yes and all that
so how would you say this EP compares to
the second one you'll release in the
fall you know we're still finishing the
second one up I still kind of don't know
what exactly the tracklist is gonna be
so it's still say that like you're
excited I'm really excited because I
have it's like I'm in a really great
position but I have too many songs that
I love so I get to sort of handpick what
is going to work out I think on that EP
but I think actually the second EP might
even be a little bit more dancey there's
a little bit more kind of like a little
more booty shakin a little bit more yeah
you're already doing it I feel the bass
are great you should I think it's gonna
be a little bit of that it's gonna be
really fun I love it well I saw you at
The Wiltern and you'd throw a dance
party song thank you all I want to do is
for everybody to come to the show and
like dance their faces off and if you
want or if you're of age just get really
drunk and like enjoy your a just have
fun I want people to come and have so
much fun I did all of the above there
you go a couple fan questions yeah after
YouTube asks are there any surprising
collabs on the new release mmm you know
it's funny we we kind of have talked
about a bunch of different collaboration
options what's his name - you said
hi we you know we've talked about a
bunch of different collaborations that
we could do and a couple people that I'm
super excited and really want to work
with but I think particularly on this
first EP maybe even the second one too I
really want to keep it like this is you
know this is just me this isn't I need
to kind of restate my claim a little bit
I think and I think if you're gonna hear
a feature anyway don't be on the on my
album okay yeah I love this so stay
tuned it's gonna be a lot of like me
kind of rediscovering what I really want
to do and then and then get to maybe
throw some fun like kind of
left-of-center snow because you also
have to introduce this next area of
Betty yeah it's like this is me the
guests will come later yeah also hence
like the album the EP title you know
it's kind of the the what I am really
trying to like communicate and it's like
this really feels like I have discovered
this whole new version of myself and I
feel really different and like so that
kind of this whole next project is very
like I want everybody to know that know
this is like this is me this is me
nobody else had a hand in this like if
you've been sykes before like cool cuz
it has been me still but there's been so
much sort of behind the scenes
tumultuous emotional kind of baggage
behind a lot of the old music and I
still love you know all my albums and
I'm proud of every single song I've ever
put out sorry but this feels very like
deliberate you know and I love that part
one actually takes on a extra meaning
yes the beginning yes just again a taste
of who I am or Who I am right now I love
that do you have any dream collaboration
so whether it's on this next album I
want I want to do a song with Liz oh
okay yeah so bad I'm obsessed with her I
think she's like the most empowered
awesome lady in the biz so Liz I was
like up there I see that I think we can
make the most badass like lady's song I
love that yeah Brian from facebook asks
if you could cover any song or you know
new album what would you do because by
the way I mean I love you forever it's
such an iconic cover it's so so good you
want to put the Betty who spin off you
know it's really funny as I was
listening to a love Shania Twain I
there's a song that you know
keeping you forever and for always I
love that song so much and I really want
to do a cover of it but the last cover I
did is I love yours forever and so to do
a cover of forever and for always I
think it's like probably a little too on
the nose
yeah that's like my dream cover that I
probably I might do like I won't do it
like like release it I might do like if
I do like a spot-up Spotify something
I'm covering a song so so keep an eye
out but I don't think it'll ever be an
official release because okay but I'm
waiting for it I'm waiting for that one
I want to take you back to 2013 Wow the
viral marriage proposal yes if you guys
haven't seen it I mean at this point a
lot of people have seen a couple got
engaged at a Home Depot
okay it was a flashmob to something like
I can't even look at it because it makes
me so emotional I literally every time
somebody hasn't seen it and they've
heard about they're like I never saw it
and I'm like watch it right now and I'll
watch it with them and I'll just be like
a hundredth time seeing this and I'm
like okay have you seen that video
Selene when she's crying she's doing
this like what do they mean yeah I mean
so all these years how does it feel to
be part of that special moment you know
I feel really lucky because Spencer and
Dustin are still friends of mine and I
still get to see them every time I'm in
Salt Lake City them and all their family
and all their friends come to the show
in Salt Lake City I always get to give
them a hug they've story I have a like a
face steamer that I like see my voice my
voice and the gift before my shows and I
spill I was like holding it and it
spilled and it's filled with boiling
water and it spilled right here and that
in that picture where I'm standing with
them I have this huge burn right in the
middle of my chest I know from my space
steamer no ideas pain so how are they I
think they have my kids now love is real
they are they
so wonderful nurse you know it's kind of
they just complete each other in a
really beautiful way and I feel I when I
started making music I kind of I like I
had this goal right if like all I want
to do is I want to make music that's the
soundtrack to people's happiest moments
in their lives you know I didn't really
want to be the artist that people listen
to you like crying in the shower I still
make their songs because I love those
songs but I think like more than
anything that's what I was like I look
at that they're so beautiful oh my god
yeah so so to have something like this
happen and I remember I saw it I didn't
know them obviously and my management
sent it to me and they were like you're
gonna die when you see this video and I
was like you're crazy that I sobbed 4
million years so I think the the
opportunity to have been a part of
somebody's like you know they're never
gonna forget that moment they're gonna
be together forever and they're gonna
talk about you know how do you propose
you know like that's that's a landmark
in their their story in their life and I
got to just like be there and be a part
of it in this really and so I got I went
to their wedding you did the I saying
somebody loves you take as they walk
down the aisles but their moms walk them
down the aisle and I could I was singing
and I was looking over here as they're
walking down here because I was I'm so
everybody was sobbing and I'm so
emotional and I was like I know I won't
be able to sing this if if I look at you
so I was like I think it got a little
teary as well I had to keep it together
they are so beautiful and they have
moved so many people and I mean they've
moved people you're that song has moved
so many people I'm assuming that at this
point you still don't get tired of
singing that song it's really funny I
get tired of singing like a lot it you
know as you're on tour every night and
I've been singing the songs from the
first EPS you know I've been singing
since 2013 that's a long time there's
not a single day somebody loves he's
really hard to perform cuz it's like one
of the hardest dance numbers just sing
it and dance at the same time and it's
the lost song in our set every night so
I'm always exhausted so that gets hard
but I'm never like I don't want to sing
this song I'm literally every time it
stops everyone is so excited to hear it
and it's like I don't I don't know if
I'll ever be over it I have fun I'm
shocked to hear you say that you get
tired physically tired performing that
song because I saw you and you are like
burying oh my god
the choreography and all your like
beautiful backup dancer the gorge I know
it was a sight for the ears and the eyes
no show I just bring them to make me
look good I love that oh speaking of
weddings I mean since you announced your
engaging planning going are you planning
I am just starting okay like now it's a
plan because we have talked about wine
to get married next summer and I feel
like I have to get my life together if
we're gonna do so yeah I'm just starting
to kind of get it together and I have a
lot of ideas but it's it's already
seeming to be quite a stressful
experience and I'm a little busy so yeah
I haven't I haven't dealt too far into
it but I'm honestly I don't think I have
because I'm so excited and I don't want
to like be stressed out by again I'd be
psyched and I've we've sort of been
living in an engagement bliss for for
about six months and it's really nice I
feel like I could just be engaged to him
for forever oh but you also need to have
that moment you know a wedding they
already know I'm gonna wear so have a
designer yeah I think I mean at least
for me I grew up going I'm gonna get
married in a Vera Wang dress that's like
you have to you have to write looks like
what I've always wanted to do so I
already know like exactly what I want to
wear but everybody tells me see this is
I haven't done I've been saving trying
on a wedding dress until we have a bunch
of keys you have to like get a bunch of
other stuff in place first and the thing
I'm the most looking forward to
obviously it's trying on the dress I'm
saving it yeah I don't like you know
kind of you know get tuned to ahead of
myself and I everyone tells me I have a
bunch of friends who also got engaged on
the same time as I did that you go in
knowing exactly what you want and you
come out with something you never
expected to get and I'm like I don't
want to hear that cuz I love the dress
but I was right but I'm obviously gonna
try on a little bit I have to you know
gonna sip on the champagne like all of
that yeah I got a fake tan for hair and
makeup
I look awesome you should get someone to
perform at your wedding I feel like you
can phone in a favor yeah well you
perform at your wedding I want I will
not perform at my wedding but I do have
a couple friends who are like some of my
really close friends who I've met sort
of through LA and also from you know my
caught with college my friend Vincent
was just on the for
he was like a you know a finalist on the
floor and he's one of my best friend
from college we've been friends for
years and so I've already asked if he
and and my friend Scott Hoying has
independent superfruit I've already
asked if the two of them will sing me
down the aisle done I know right okay
what'll I not I have a year to scorn in
right Dedra from YouTube ask Betty
what's the craziest story you can tell
us involving a celebrity fan of yours Oh
a celebrity fan okay hi Deidre um let me
think about it
celebrity fan this is kind of like
random but this is the first thing that
comes to mind when I when I went to a
Grammy I played it like a Grammy potty
the friends-and-family Grammy party and
I was I was performing and a bunch of
people that I knew and it was obvious it
was like one of my first times
performing for anybody you know I like
any celebrities or anybody I'd kind of
been touring I've been playing for like
100 people in New York you know it was
like so low-key and I was walking up
there it was in this huge like hole that
had this huge like a staircase in the
middle of it it was so like fab
everybody's making entrances on the
staircase right so I'm walking up the
stairs or I think I was walking down the
stairs and someone I see someone like
kind of like running up the stairs
towards me and she grabs this one lady
grabs my hand and I'm kind of like
there's so much going on that I'm not
really paying attention she grabs my
hand and she goes you're Betty right and
I was like yeah and she goes Betty I
love you I'm Michelle Branch I was like
hi Michelle Branch like I love you too
and she was like I'm gonna talk to you
later and then she ran away and I was
like okay that she did time you later we
ended up like getting brunch and hanging
out and she's like literally the best oh
my god no but I was like Michelle Branch
I love you my early 2000 I feel like I
don't know why I feel this way but I
feel like there are like specific people
who I loved growing up like John Tucker
Must I was on my favorite movies like of
my teenage years I loved that movie and
well my favorite people in it was tufi a
bush and so now she's become like one of
my best friends and I'm obsessed with
her and like she came into my life and
she was coming to my shows and she liked
her and her friend group found my EP and
then they basically they booked me at an
event that they were all running like
would the intention is basically like
like stealing me and nothing me their
friend and I was like this really works
for me it's great
I really love it i've been friends for
years now what a crazy life I know this
is a crazy life
Kiran from YouTube is asking what music
you were listening to right now you know
in the spirit of new music Friday
totally - hi Karen
I cannot get over Troye Sivan ever so my
my my is still I still to this day like
the only thing I every day I listen to
about what performed it live with Taylor
Swift
Victoria Secret way I saw I saw breather
I wasn't there okay I was there I was
really sad I actually missed the show oh
wow you they were walk rushing I'm
retired you kidding they both had this
Instagram killed me when he was like I
cannot believe I did the Victoria Secret
wait wait and and someone goes it on his
comment someone said like who are you
waving to and he says I have no idea I
was possessed by the power yeah I was
killed you know other song I love is I
want you back by 5 seconds of summer huh
okay that's a summer but oh my god the
first time I heard it I was like what a
song yeah obviously the new Shawn Mendes
came out and I was actually starting to
listen to it on the way over here and
it's in my blood I love yes so like
Kings of Leon E okay yeah like it's just
like his whole daughters on it yeah I
think that I think that Shawn is like it
really excites me
Shawn works so hard like I only know
this because we had the same voice
teacher and he told me how hard Sean
works like in his lessons with him and
like - I think he sounds incredible and
he's so talented I think we have like
needed and honest like him for a really
long time and for someone to come from I
think people have a lot of to prove when
they come from the internet like I feel
that way I had this viral video and now
I'm like I have to like stake my claim
as being right kind of so I think Shawn
you know he came from vine right mm-hmm
and so I think he's somebody who could
have been like oh he's that vine kid and
it's like no look at him he's a star and
his songs are so good I think he's so
talented I'm super psyched for him John
Mayer even said he's John Mayer but
better John Mayer loves him that's
really funny yeah I want to end on this
note okay great but you know what
June is Pride Month and you have so many
LGBTQ fans I mean what message you want
to send out to those fans in particular
and ones who are inspired by you and
your music
you know I I think I feel really like
blessed and lucky to have been sort of
falling into this this world where I get
to play a bunch of Pride festivals and I
say this all the time you know I pride
is literally exactly that it's a
celebration of people coming to be
themselves and to celebrate who they are
fundamentally regardless of what anybody
else thinks that they should be and I
think that that is one of the most
beautiful and kind of important things
that I have I feel like I've learned so
much being a part of the LGBTQ community
and being an ally and I think that if I
had like a message it would be like keep
being you because I feel this way all
the time and it's you know in my life
around my music anything it's like there
are so many people every single day who
tell me that I should do something
differently or be different from close
friends and family to thinking you know
everybody has their own life and they're
everybody's the most important person
you everyone's the star of their own
movie right and so I think so many
people want to impose what they think
you should do on to you and I think
trusting yourself and like knowing that
you are nobody can make the best
decisions for you except for you and
believing in yourself in that way it's
like the thing that has helped me like
grow up and be confident and I love
myself there's no better gift than to
know who you are and then to live it
yeah be a pony unapologetically yeah
exactly literally I've seen you know
sometimes I talk about seeing performers
where I feels like them being on stage
is like sort of an apology like sorry to
take up your time and it's like oh it's
like this is your moment like your life
is your moment yeah just like to be here
and like don't apologize for being you
it literally ever right like Beyonce
said at the end of one torch goes I'm
yours
so thank you guys what you're talking
about the I am I am yours like I will do
this as long and achieve
[Music]
okay we're gonna do like a screening
that I am all the tours so much for
coming to hang out with us and yeah I
had a blast enjoy the long weekend we'll
be back on Tuesday with a brand new
daily Denny until then thank you for
coming thank you so much for being here
guys go stream and download taste betty
part one out June 15
let's go cop that are you guys we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]